[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is ender Paul gruel a professor of
women's gender and sexuality studies she
is also a professor in the ethnicity
race and migration program and the South
Asian Studies Council as well as an
affiliate faculty member in the American
Studies program professor Brule is the
author of home and harem nation gender
Empire and the cultures of travel and
transnational America feminism's
diasporas neoliberalism's she has also
published several edited and co edited
collections her ongoing projects include
essays on the relation between trans
national media and corruption and sexual
violence today we'll talk with Professor
gruel about her forthcoming book the
masculinity z' of post-colonial
governance bureaucratic memoirs of the
Indian civil service
welcome professor girl thank you let's
begin with an overview of your book tell
us about it well the book is looking at
a number of memoirs that have been
published since India became independent
in 1947 and this is about elite civil
servants who wrote a number of memoirs
about their lives and about their
service and I'm looking at these memoirs
that were published since independence
but it started with the civil servants
who came from the British period into a
day and after into Indian government
after independence and then I'm looking
since that period to people who were
recruited or passed exams and became
part of this elite civil service since
then and sort of up through 1990 okay so
there's kind of a mix of people yes
alright let's talk about the terms
masculinities and bureaucratic memoirs
tell us about those terms
what they mean those terms are really
important to understand from the
viewpoint of feminist scholarship what's
going on in independent India in the way
in which people are governed and what's
important about the masculinities part
is for us to understand how is
bureaucracy a masculine occupation what
is it that tells us about the ways in
which these people govern how they
relate to the people who they govern how
they relate to men and women among the
people they are governing how they pay
attention to women but also how they see
themselves what are their relationships
with others in the bureaucracy what are
their relationships with their families
what are their relationships with those
people who are their spirits and with
politicians so I'm looking at a set of
relationships that constitute what
people and how people think of
themselves and what people think of
bureaucracy to be okay what gave you the
idea what was the catalyst of writing
this book you know the catalyst was I
was looking at a case of sexual
harassment of an elite civil servant in
Punjab
during the 1980s when there was an
insurgency going on at that in that
region and I was looking at a very
famous case her name was Reuben bill
Bajaj and she accused a police officer
of sexual harassment and she was an
elite civil servant herself but she was
in the civilian sector and he was in the
police so I was very curious about how
is it that in this moment of insurgency
that this case could become so notorious
how is it that she could win judgments
in different courts against this police
officer even though the government was
very much in favor of using this police
officer to control the insurgency so I
was very curious how is it that she was
getting so much traction in this case
because one of the things we know
from family scholarships this great deal
of sexual harassment that goes on
there's a great deal of generalized
violence against women that happens in
most every society and it's only very
recently that we've started to pay
attention anywhere to employment and
harassment within context of employment
so I was very curious about what was
going on in that time so as I started to
follow this case one of the interesting
things that came out of this case was it
wasn't so much a personal issue it was
an issue of one bureaucracy against
another bureaucracy that the Civil
Service was very upset that the police
service had so much power over
governance in the region at that time so
it became a broader issue of the
question of bureaucracy contest stations
between bureaucracies and the ways in
which sexual different sexual violence
harassment could become a tool used in
this kind of power struggle between
bureaucracies now it surprises me to
hear you say that there was a woman
public in public service was that
commonplace for the time you know ever
since independence and the creation of
the civil service there have been
conversations over including more women
even at independence as some of the
nationalist leaders who were who had
been very much part of the struggle for
independence argued about how the
country should be governed and there
were many who argued that they that
India should just continue with the
British civil service just use and
continue that civil service into the
post-independence period and they saw
this as as central to maintaining a
control and power and portunity in order
in the country after independence so and
that faction did win and one of the
issues that came up right at
Independence
was that women nationalist leaders work
were arguing that we should have more
women in the bureaucracy from the get-go
- from the start so this was an issue
that started at the very moment of
independence when people were
negotiating what the civil service
should be who should be in it what kinds
of people should be in it whether the
characteristics we need in it so this
was an issue at the beginning though
when they were thinking about how to
include women in the civil service there
the path in the civil service was often
quite different for women than for men
so generally and this was part of what
the British civil service had started a
people who passed the exams to be part
of the civil service were at the first
instance in the apprenticeship years
sent to rural areas so they had postings
in rural areas where they worked with
other people where they've where they
came to know the region came to know the
people the local people and this was
supposed to get them into much more of
becoming much more familiar with
governing at a smaller rural scale so it
was kind of like a triangle but at the
at the get after independence it was
often argued that if women became part
of civil service they would not be safe
if they just went to rural areas on
their own so had they had different
kinds of jobs allocated to them but this
also meant that they couldn't follow the
the normative path to rising to the top
of the bureaucracy just because they
didn't have that rural experience and so
this has changed over time of course but
at the beginning this was an issue
another issue was should they remain in
the civil service after they got married
should they have to leave the civil
service once they got married so this
was another issue that was raised at the
beginning but was of course resolved
later on that you know women can stay as
long as
they're up to their retirement age so
thieves there's there are some ways in
which women's path and civil service
they rule was somewhat different at the
beginning okay so how did you
let's first I'd like to know what's the
difference between a bureaucratic memoir
and for instance an autobiography that's
a really good question
so autobiographies if you look at the
key autobiographies in that came out in
India it was sort of Nehru the leaders
of the nation writing about their lives
and how they became leaders right and
there have been other autobiographies as
well but these were very powerful people
very influential people reflecting upon
their lives there's also been
autobiographies of authors writers who
wrote about themselves and these were
often deeply personal write a Gandhi's
autobiographies are all about his
struggles with his self and how to forge
become a leader how to deal with with
questions of personal spiritual
struggles how to forge a new India all
of those questions but they came from
very personal struggles in some ways
these memoirs are not so much personal
and what they are is they deliberately
leave out the personal aspects so they
will not talk about marriage they will
not talk about love they will not talk
about family they will not talk about
any about the household and so these
memoirs are more designed to be lessons
in governance how to govern this is what
I did as a governor this is what I
became as a bureaucrat this is what the
formation of the bureaucrat rather than
the formation of the person right so in
the autobiography the leader the person
becomes intertwined in some way in these
memoirs it's all about you know how I
became this indeed civil servants what
were the formative professional
routes that I took it's a basically job
and career and that was it which is very
interesting I mean how how did you find
these or it seems like a very it's a
unique I think is it a unique thing to
who actually you know especially in the
first generation of civil servants these
are very literate people many of them
were very educated many of them have
been educated Oxford and Cambridge they
were used to writing you know they grew
they they were saw themselves as the
leaders of the nation setting the path
to nationhood and they were they thought
very well of themselves they were
powerful being in the British civil
service had made them extremely powerful
extremely influential so because of that
power and influence I think that they
thought very well of themselves and
their ability and their opinions and so
they were very ready to share those
opinions with subsequent generations the
other reason was I think what happens
after independence is that many people
come to view this particular group of
civil servants which is the Indian
Administrative Service it's called the
IAS and it it was it was a kind of civil
service that that case saw itself as
sort of coming continuous having some
continuity with the British civil
service so many of the British civil
servants became part of the Indian
Administrative Service and it's an elite
service right so they were elite people
in it so part of the reason was they
were elite they saw themselves as very
important and the majority of those
people were men not women majority men
and what's remarkable in is how many of
them in that first generation after
independence wrote about these memoirs
many of them had important papers that
subsequently other generations put
together in forms of a memoir too so
what I'm interested
is how do people remember these civil
servants and why do they remember some
of them more than others right how did
you how did you find these memoirs and
how did you choose which ones to use for
your book and just basically how what
were your methodology was so when I
started to look into these there was so
many and I have found that every lecture
that I give on this topic I will find
someone or the other coming up to me and
saying have you read thus and such
memoir so there are a tremendous number
some are published by very prominent
publishers in India Rupa & Company is
one of those that has published many of
them and some some are self-published
some are very small presses that are
hard for me have been hard for me to
find so I'm always on the search for
these memoirs as well any we're written
by women that's a really good question
it's harder to find me else so as I do
this work on the book what I'm trying to
see is what are the forms of writing
that the women bureaucrats offered right
and what I find is that their subsequent
generation their children grandchildren
have not taken that much time to put
together their papers and made them
published and available to others so
it's been harder for me to find some of
those so what I do is combine a little
bit of of interviewing oral histories
I'm trying to look at newspapers seeing
if there are cases of you know sexual
harassment was one example I did you and
when I found that that story then I went
and spoke to the so servant who was the
center of the case and she gave me a
bunch of her papers so it's been a
little bit of detective work sleuthing
chasing after leads and people telling
me about
okay so how many ultimately did you
include in the book well I am in the
process of writing the book so I haven't
finished it I'm still looking for them I
have a whole bunch of the high caste
men's memoirs
those are the published forms I'm still
not completely done with the research on
finding the the civil servants who came
from the Dalits who were part of the
late witches the formerly lower caste
the Untouchables but they're back group
I'm still looking for their work and
I've found some and they're so
interesting because some of those are
more concerned we're talking about the
discrimination that they per they faced
in their professional lives so they
become much more deeply personal than
the other ones that I'm looking at
so they deal with the discrimination how
they are in a profession where there are
many elite high caste people and they
enter this profession from a very
different community and come to have
very different experiences so that kind
of clear division between public life
and private life that I saw in the
memoirs of the high caste bureaucrats is
maybe going to be is going to be quite
different when I when I write about the
ballot well that actually leads me to a
fascinating I think question in terms of
there was no discrimination of who can
actually be a civil servant so they were
openly able to become one but then they
were discriminated once they became one
right isn't that interesting
it is interesting but they weren't
barred from becoming one I'm gonna get
go you know they aren't and actually
they're they have affirmative action
programs now for different groups right
right but at the same time when you
think about how people become
bureaucrats it's by these very intense
exams that you have to take and so the
question is who is able to be who is
prepared to take the exam becomes the
issue that we face here in the US with
the SATs and the other exams so you will
find more privileged people who get
tutoring I'm more prepared have an
advantage to be able to take these exams
and people who have you know struggle to
find that find the books are from
low-income communities who don't have
the education that allows them to excel
as much so they're they're disadvantaged
anyway so even though it seems like
meritocracy is actually not a
meritocracy okay
so are you planning on including any of
the women's memoirs in your book I've
found really interesting accounts in
oral histories and I am going to include
them I will I have a I have a chapter on
them but it's going to be an interesting
chapter because it's again going to be
much more personal than the ones that I
have thus far written about the high
caste men write about that so once again
it's more about struggles it's about
personal lives and I'll tell you one
interesting story I was chasing down one
woman bureaucrat and I found that she
had passed away and I went to meet her
husband to ask him about whether he had
any papers whether there was anything
that I could use from her life in order
to write in my chapter and he handed me
a book of poetry he said you know read
this this is where she really expresses
herself and that was so striking to me
that instead of a book that was about
here's how to govern here's what
subsequent generations might do she has
this deeply personal way to think but of
course that's only a small part of the
story I am sure that with you know
different generations of women how they
express themselves how this
themselves a bureaucrat has also changed
so that will be interesting for me to
look at okay
so ultimately you know why is it
important to look at these kinds of
memoirs in terms of the larger picture
of life during that time yeah I think
it's really important because one these
people are very much in charge of the
lives of and the welfare of so many
people right and to understand their
motivations to understand what their
networks are to understand who they
favor who they can have empathy with who
they can think about who how they view
different groups of people and the kind
of ways in which the diversity of India
itself demands certain kinds of
knowledge and empathy of people means
that you have to understand bureaucrats
really well so far historians have
looked at many of these memoirs as just
an archive that here's what I can look
at into finding out into writing a
historical narrative of a period of a
another person nobody has really looked
at these memoirs as a kind of literary
genre of a bureaucracy how does the
bureaucracy write itself so this is what
I'm interested in how does a bureaucracy
write itself how does a bureaucracy
write itself as a gendered human being
as belonging to a particular group as
seeing themselves as part of a important
part of the nation itself so and what
we've seen in India today is since this
civil service is so dogged with charges
of corruption people even from
independence common people think of them
as two elite as two corrupt as uncaring
of ordinary people's lives
as only telling to the politicians so
there's a great deal of suspicion among
ordinary people in India of this very
elite group and I'm also trying
interesting in thinking about well how
does that suspicion translate into the
way they behave is that suspicion
justified what is the what is the fear
of corruption how does it affect these
people does it change their behavior
does it make them more open to all kinds
of people what does it do in the matter
of governance right well we will look
forward to learning more about that when
your book comes out thank you for being
here thank you for having me okay for
more information about Professor grewal
and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you
[Music]